morbius est un personnage merveilleux qui a été
une partie importante de l'univers,
il est brillant, je suis pur,
c'est curieusement possible, il est fort,
il a des pouvoirs uniques
mais ses pouvoirs semblent hors de son
contrôle,
ce qui se passe,
j'adore l'opportunité de faire quelque chose de
transformationnel.  Je suis devenu quelque chose
de différent,
c'était un rôle physique très intense,
plus parce que c'est le plus fragile et ensuite le
plus monstrueux,
ce super méchant super-héros
mettant à l'écran un nouveau personnage Marvel
qui n'avait jamais été à l'écran auparavant,
ce sera amusant de voir où nous pourrions  va
sans toi, il y a un réseau d'opportunités